[Music]
everybody makes mistakes everybody has
those days animators have a hard job but
sometimes they make pretty noticeable
mistakes stay tuned to hear more about
the mistakes and shows like the loud
house and door the Explorer
if you're new here make sure to
subscribe to the things and give our
video a big thumbs up if you love
Nickelodeon now let's check out 10
animation mistakes in Nickelodeon shows
only true fans noticed Spongebob
Squarepants we have to start with one of
Nickelodeon's most popular shows ever
whether you love it or hate it you have
to admit that SpongeBob SquarePants is
absolutely iconic the shows so wacky and
crazy sometimes fans forget to focus on
the smallest details shout out to the
biggest fans of the show that we're able
to note some of these animation mistakes
but one of the biggest animation errors
goes against everything we've ever known
about Sponge Bob
we all know that Sponge Bob is basically
a sponge but if you dive into this
theory more it might lead to an
existential crisis in some episodes
spongebob is clearly shown without any
bones are even a brain which explains
quite a lot of things but it seems like
nickelodeon sometimes forgot about the
spongy details because we've actually
seen him with bones in several episodes
in I had an accident his x-rays clearly
see that he has bones and no weenies
allowed he breaks his fingers in squid
on strike we see his skeleton come on
Nickelodeon if spongebob was really a
sponge there's no way he'd have bones
that would resemble a human at all of
course there are plenty of more
animation mistakes coming from the show
so make sure to watch our other videos
if you want to see more Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles in 2012 Nickelodeon
edition of Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
gave everyone's favorite turtle
characters brand new definition we were
finally able to see more details of our
fighting heroes such as their eye colors
a distinctly shaped head height
difference and other features we
normally wouldn't notice because of
old-school animations but the series
also came with some animation mistakes
and continuity errors did you ever
notice that in the 2012 version of the
series all turtles have 3 toes but in
previous versions they'd always have
only 2 while it might not be an error it
definitely draws attention these ninja
turtles also have different color wraps
on both their feet and wrists leonardo
has a light peach color
Donatello comes with golden brown
Michelangelo has light brown and Raphael
has dark brown we preferred it when
these wraps matched the color of their
eye mask it's technically not an
animation mistake but we'd rather not
see it happen you can also find several
audio mistakes in this series like in
season 1 episode 12 we're in one of his
teens Michelangelo and Donatello slips
don't really match to what they're
saying
come on Nickelodeon if we know you can
do better than that invaders them
invader zim was one of those awesome
shows we never wanted to see end well
unfortunately it did ends in 2004 after
only a couple of seasons and to be
completely honest with you we still miss
it so we're bringing it back just to
show you some super specific animation
mistakes because we've really just
wanted to play a couple of episodes all
over again pay attention to the 15th
episode of season one also known as
mysterious mysteries in one of the
beginning scenes we see the host getting
worried because he doesn't have any
material for his show after the crazy
stuff Dib keeps sending end gets
suggested the host gets a flashback
where you can see the scar on his cheek
right after Dib appears for a brief
second his scar disappears just a few
seconds after we see the host looking at
a picture of pig foot the first time you
see it pig foot has a pink nose mask and
the second time the color of the mask
fades away to animation mistakes one
after another
have you noticed these before Rugrats
super fans of Rugrats already know this
show comes with plenty of mistakes but
just how many have you noticed we love
re watching the episodes of these wacky
kids but it's even funnier when we have
to pay attention to possible animation
errors you just never know when they're
going to pop out remember season three's
episode called pickles vs. pickles when
the parents go to sleep the night after
Angelica freaks out and says they'll be
sorry for making her do things she
doesn't want you can see Charlotte's
sleeping on the left side of the bed and
drew on the right but when Drew wakes up
he suddenly is on the left side of the
bed even though we all know that what
had happened was just a dream
was his nightmare so powerful and made
him switch the side of the bed with his
wife
maybe he literally got up on the wrong
side of the bed and why does Charlotte
go to bed with full on makeup a ponytail
and her iconic earrings that
doesn't seem very comfortable and she's
magically able to wake up without having
her makeup smudged at all must be all
the animation magic Hey Arnold speaking
of some of our favorite shows we
absolutely have to talk about hey Arnold
it's one of those series we're
definitely still not over and we have so
many questions that were left unanswered
the show entertained us for the longest
time and sometimes we love to rewatch
some of the episodes just so we feel a
little bit nostalgic come on we know you
do this - have you ever paid attention
to the theme song of the show how could
you not it's totally iconic but next
time you're watching it try to focus on
Herald's - seriously just focus on it
for the entire opening song and see if
you can notice anything strange when the
boys line up for a standoff against the
girls
you'll notice that Harold's tooth does
something strange we all know it's
usually located on the left but for some
reason it switches to the right side for
a brief second you can see it briefly
when Arnold already strikes a pose but
Harold and Gerald are still working on
it
the tooth goes right back to normal just
a second later why would they even put
it on the wrong side of his mouth The
Fairly OddParents
speaking of shows that never get old we
love the fact that as of February 2018
The Fairly OddParents is still going
strong after ten seasons
who doesn't love this wacky show and
it's even crazier characters well if you
need an excuse to go rewatch it will
give you a few we see Timmy drinking a
slushy and getting a brain freeze in
true to me fashion he slams his head on
the table Cosmo doesn't really know
what's happening so he asks what brain
freeze actually is nothing wrong about
that right wrong because in season 5
episode 5 we see Cosmo turning into an
ice cream and practically eating himself
he actually gets a brain freeze and he
seems to know pretty well what that is
the ran and stimpy show don't judge us
for liking this bizarre show it's
actually pretty interesting when to
embrace the fact that it's super old and
weird although there aren't many
animation mistakes that we were able to
catch in the Ren & Stimpy show we did
manage to see one that was actually
pointed out by hardcore fans in season 1
episode 3 we see the gritty Kitty
commercial now pay attention to this
where mr. horse takes a sniff of the
litter boxes marked a and B if you've
never watched this show before you don't
question it we promise it'll all make
sense or maybe it won't when mister
horse smells the litter box a it smells
pretty bad but pay attention to the
letter on the letterbox B when mr. horse
turns his head to the camera you can see
the letter change back to the letter B
this had no connection to the actual
plot so we're pretty sure it was just
another animation mistake unless the
whole point was that the entire thing
was just a big lie although that's not
the point of this episode at all
seriously if you've never watched the
Rin instantiy show you need to give it a
try because it's pretty great Dora the
Explorer when it comes to iconic
Nickelodeon shows who can possibly
forget about Dora most of us grew up on
it and Dora probably taught us more
Spanish than we're willing to admit she
was awesome but we bet you were too
young to notice that the show had quite
a few animation errors we obviously
can't go through them all but have you
ever caught this interesting error in
the actual theme song of the show go
watch season one's opening scene and pay
attention to everything you see on the
left side of the screen you'll notice
that the top left side isn't animated
properly if you pay attention to the top
half and watch Dora and other characters
walk across you can see that every
single character can still be seen after
they disappear behind the cave did no
one on the animation team notice that
the characters aren't actually
disappearing as they should be we all
know animators have a tough job and
putting together every detail can be
quite hard but this just seems like they
had no idea how to fix that issue so
they just left it the way it is avatar
the last airbender we're really just
mentioning this one because the gesture
made all of us want to ball our eyes out
but then it was never mentioned again if
you're a true fan you know what we're
talking about avatar the last airbender
is without a doubt one of our favorite
shows of all time even though it
finished in 2008 we all know that egg
had romantic feelings for Katara while
the show revolves around a lot of things
we see this beautiful friendship unfold
when Katara lost her mother's beloved
necklace we see Aang to make her a new
one in episode 14 of the first season
but when the group reaches the next
village the necklace
nowhere to be found and to make things
even worse it's never mentioned again
seriously Katara never speaks about this
DIY necklace and no one ever brings it
up again how can something that seems so
important just disappear didn't the
necklace play an important part in
Katara and Aang x'b on either the loss
of the necklace is a plot twist we never
noticed or nickelodeon animators are
unintentionally playing with our fragile
hearts seriously we'll never forgive you
for this one guys we want to know what
happened to the necklace the loud house
okay if you watch our videos you know
this is not a secret the loud house is
actually one of our favorite Nickelodeon
shows ever yep we like it even better
than Sponge Bob sorry spongebob this
show is absolutely gorgeous but we all
know that nobody's perfect so even our
absolute fave has to make mistakes but
that's totally fine because it makes
things a lot more interesting for the
show's super fans like this strange twin
Anatomy in the very first episode where
we see Lola and Lana scream because
they're scared but if you pay attention
to their arms you'll see that they get
scared so hard their arms actually
completely separate from their bodies
this show also frequently forgets that
one of Lincoln's features is his chip
tooth in fact sometimes they even forget
to draw it on from the second episode of
season one we see Lincoln into Lori's
room which is a total nono when he
realizes where he is he gets scared but
if you look at his teeth you'll see that
his chipped tooth is nowhere to be found
we wish our teeth could be fixed as fast
as Lincoln's work we told you where the
show's biggest superfans we take
animation mistakes very seriously don't
forget to let us know some of the
mistakes you've managed to spot and
Nickelodeon shows that's it for our
video for more videos like this one
check out ten mistakes and Nickelodeon
shows you missed as a kid from Screen
Rant don't forget to subscribe to the
things see you next time
[Music]